American Enterprise Fellow and former
speechwriter and special assistant to
President Bush
William Middendorf and David from Sunday
at 6:00 and 9:00 p.m. Eastern on
afterwards on c-span - afterwards is
also available each week as a c-span
podcast empires workshop is Greg
Brandon's examination of US intervention
in Latin America from Thomas Jefferson
to the current Bush administration
Sunday on book TV joined the NYU
professor and contributor to the nation
arbors and the New York Times for
discussion at the Heart Institute in
California the US and Latin America
Sunday at 1:15 a.m. Eastern here on book
TV the great proletarian Cultural
Revolution was launched in China in 1966
by Chinese Communist Party chair molls
Aydin next Harvard political science
professor Roderick mark FACA he argues
that the mass executions and human
rights violations that occurred during
this period set the stage for a more
democratic China this is around 50
minutes tonight however we are here to
listen to Roderick mcfar car author of
mouths last revolution razmik Parker has
had a number of careers he was a
journalist with the Daily Telegraph
and Sunday Telegraph from 1955 to 1961
editor the china quarterly from 1959 to
1968 elected to the house of parliament
on representing belper in 1974 received
his PhD from the university of london in
1981 and simpson and has held numerous
posts and currently he is the Leroy B
Williams professor of history and
political science and please join me in
welcoming professor Makar car
[Applause]
thanks very much thanks very much to all
of you for coming I must say I'm a
little bit new to this book signing lark
I thought it was only for people like
Tom Clancy and Noam Chomsky in fact I've
been hoping that some Chinese would
stand up at the UN and denounce my book
and make it notorious because no Chinese
going to stand up and praise it that's
for sure and that's actually one reason
why we did this book and that is because
some the Chinese have tried to sweep the
Cultural Revolution under the carpet and
last year I was told by a quite recent
old by Chinese editors senior Chinese
editor that last year the propaganda
department said there will be no
celebration of the 40th anniversary of
the Cultural Revolution no marking of
celebration of course they wouldn't do
but no marking of it even and very few
books actually on the culture revolution
have been published in China a couple
two or three quite good ones by trusted
scholars and they have hewn the party
line even while they have been saying
quite interesting things and we thought
that it was time that the Cultural
Revolution should be written about and
there should be a record as we say if
you look at the at the dedication it is
a dedication to those Chinese who have
informed us with their knowledge and
their ideas but it's also a dedication
to all those will come after us when
they are clear to write and they are at
the moment about the convolution why
aren't be able to write there are there
was right because the Chinese publishes
some of you will know in 1981 they
published a resolution on party history
which explained the Cultural Revolution
and it did plain mouth for having the
big idea the wrong big idea of having a
Cultural Revolution but that's it all
the blame for all the nastiness
terrible chaos and the killings went on
were pretty well blamed on the gang of
four on Marshall in VR by then is dead
and the idea of this resolution as
indeed with all party resolutions is to
make sure that everyone starts thinking
on the right line so that they don't go
outside those boundaries and they
haven't and there are people fascinated
with the felt revolution living in China
Chinese scholars they do write they do
talk but if they publish they publish in
Hong Kong
sometimes in Taiwan by usually Hong Kong
so this is in part an effort sort of
putting it down on paper for the first
generation of truly free Chinese
historians to start off with perhaps the
second reason we did is because I have
been teaching a course on the culture
evolution since the late 80s and for
that purpose since there were quite a
few students I had to have a source book
and as I compiled a source book I
realized that all the writings in
English because these were undergrads
who didn't they're Chinese all their
writings in English were dating back to
the time of the Cultural Revolution
itself or just after and basically it
was the history of the victors the
victors in the calculation and not the
history of the survivors those who
survived the Cultural Revolution like
Dan Xia Bing and all the others and so
though I think it's fair to say that a
lot of journalists a lot of scholars got
things very right about what was
happening during the Cultural Revolution
I have to say that because my late wife
myself also writing about it at the time
though that a lot of people got main
threads right I think it's fair to say
that the kind of massive documentation
and the memoir literature the texts of
various party internal documents
the histories of individuals lives being
in pool
so the chronologies of party activities
all these things have come out in the
last 25 years and while they are all
supposedly not outside the resolution of
1980 ones format i've cited some
strictures nevertheless it tells you
enormous ly greater amount about the
cultural evolution
then the people writing about it at the
time do one very tiny example and I want
to go on to more important issues a
minute
Stanley Conner of the Pulitzer Prize
winning journalist wrote a very good
book about the cult revolution I think
is still running while he wrote it and
in a footnote he says that he was
writing about the big military
confrontational potential confrontation
of Wuhan in the summer of 67
he said the footnote there's some rumor
that Chairman Mao was there at the time
where he was there and we know exactly
what he was doing there now we have his
conversations with the general who was
the danger at the time thought to be the
danger and we know how he was quickly
smuggled out of the city because Joe and
I thought he was going to be killed and
I thought Marv was going to accuse and
we didn't know that at the time so it's
this kind of detail that we don't know
we also don't know the kind of detail
that came out in a book of memoirs very
recently by the then the person who was
first secretary of the Shanghai party
not a very lucky post to being as it now
seems in the in 65 when the preparations
for the Cultural Revolution was starting
many of you will remember that Mao sent
his wife Jiang Qing down to Shanghai to
get a scholar journalist propagandist
Yan Yan to write an article attacking a
member of the Peking party machine and
this is going to be the first assault on
the peaking party which my wish to
dissolve and suddenly the first
secretary died and the new first
secretary was appointed and the new
first secretary was
not in on the plot and the two
propagandists who in charge of the
article felt very nervous
so Jung Ching went to the new first
secretary and explained what was
happening and what he should have done
according to party discipline was to
have informed Beijing he should have
informed actually the man who was going
to be the principal victim because he
was in charge of these kind of cultural
matters at the time but he didn't now
I'm not saying that had he done it
there wouldn't have been a Cultural
Revolution mal would have found some
other way to have their head of Cultural
Revolution but it wouldn't start it that
way if it had been Oh revealed and it's
even conceivable that had people have
known in advance that the Chairman was
plotting this kind of thing it's
conceivable though I think based on
later behavior unlikely that that they
would have ganged up and said look
chairman you can't do this this is just
going to vow we followed you up till now
but not they're going to destroy the
leadership of the party so there have
been all sorts of things you've got to
call these memoirs this particular
member only came out actually about 18
months two years ago and the interesting
thing about it was that this is a man
who many people in the party might have
felt angry about because he'd failed to
follow discipline and he failed in
effect to help prevent the Cultural
Revolution study in the way it did so
this book was only published when all
the people in the photographs with him
at the beginning of the book who were
all victims of the Cultural Revolution
though they survived most of them were
dead so there could be no comeback no
attack on his book saying this book
reveals how dreadfully this man
disobeyed party discipline and these
pictures were designed to show that all
these guys whom in a sense he betrayed
had forgiven him because they showed him
smiling with them after the Cultural
Revolution was over for importantly I
think one of the things we try to do
here is to look a more candid a at the
chairman
role in the culture revolution then was
done in the ag-1 resolution and more
candidly than people in the mainland can
say now anyone who went to China and
michi after the Cultural Revolution will
remember that people talking about the
Gang of Four told by the Cultural
Revolution say yes the Gang of Four and
they waggle their thumb to indicate that
they all knew that the big picture the
big person was Chairman Mao and that he
was actually made at a gang of five but
that doesn't come out in the official
histories I hope that those of you who
read our book will feel that it comes
out in our book what I think we try to
suggest is that the Chairman as is well
known did not like routine he was not an
organization man he wasn't a Stalin if
any one he can be compared with it was
Hitler he didn't like anything except
the big picture and he left organization
and the nitty-gritty to other people to
carry out for him and he loved upheaval
he reveled in the fact that there was
civil war going on when he spoke to
foreigners it sound as if he regretted
it it was all great tragedy but actually
when he spoke to his intimates the
members of the Cultural Revolution group
including his wife and others and he
obviously reveled in it and I think one
of the things about the Cultural
Revolution
and not necessarily the main reason why
he launched it is because if you had a
straight Soviet style regime in China
five-year plans everything carefully
organized the Chairman had no role he
wasn't good at that kind of thing he
wouldn't be setting the agenda any
longer Joanne I could do that you shout
he could do that and he would be cast
aside not literally but metaphorically
and I think part of the reason why he
launched the Cultural Revolution is that
this way he was setting the agenda and
continuing to be the real leader of
China and we tried to show that he was
as guilty as in fact his wife said at
her
trial in 1980-81 if I remember the words
I was Chairman Mao's dog and when he
said bite I bit and she was absolutely
telling the truth of course no one there
liked to hear this but it was true and
we tried to document that the second
thing we try to do is we try to have a
more realistic appraisal of the last st.
in the Communist Pantheon because Mars
obviously no longer a saint and that's
Joan Lyon and there's always been a lot
of stuff said about Joe and I and
Chinese have said it that he saved how
many people and he did his best to keep
the country going and so did second half
of that is true but he didn't save
anyone whom he didn't get permission
from the chairman first to save he did
not stick his neck out ever and what's
more he actually was chair of one of the
committee's the case central case
examination group that actually did the
analysis and they drew up the
indictments of many of his old
colleagues so I think that I think in
fact on the mainland I've been some
hints that Joan lie is no longer it's
recognized that Joanne lie is not in
fact as saintly and he was made out to
be and in fact Deng Xiaoping laid the
foundation for this in his interview
with the recently deceased
Oriana Fallaci when he said in I think
1980 during the Cultural Revolution
Dunc Xiao Peng did and said many things
Joanne lied did and said many things he
would rather not have said and done but
he didn't specify what and we've tried
to specify so another thing that we I
think we bring out is some of the
reasons for the Chinese end of the sino
us breakthrough with the Nixon visit we
have more material that hasn't been
published before about what was not
known before which is that during the
border clashes on the northeast water in
1969 spring there were in fact three
clashes that are - as has normally been
said and in the third clash the Russians
beat the hell out of the Chinese and I
think that from the Chinese end we know
that chairman mao became obsessed with
the idea that sometime in the follow-up
to that those clashes and attempt to
bring some kind of peace to the border
that the russians would launch a Pearl
Harbor type attack against against China
and it was that that led to the break
between him and lianbao in my view we
have a discussion of that in the book
about how lindau listening tomorrow as
you always did you very carefully did
never sign the document until he found
out what Mao was going to say about the
document Mao had drawn his circle as
they tended to do he would put his
circle also on the document and on this
occasion he'd even hearing mouths
speaking for months and months about the
danger of a surprise attack so what is
one of the great generals of the
Communist revolution the defense
minister the heir apparent what is he
supposed to do under the second as well
what he should do is prepare the country
for this surprise attack so he decided
to do it and he issued what was
circulated as deputy supreme commander
Lin brows first order and all over the
country troops moved aircraft were
dispersed ships moved it was an
incredible movement and in fact so
incredible that I spoken to people on
the American side they all noticed it
they wondered what was happening were
they about to attack Taiwan Babacan what
was really going on and since the since
the Americans I'm told now well
also doing the maneuver to try and
frighten the Russians it looked like
there was a lot of military movement
going on but the crux for Chairman Mao
was in my view the following without him
signing off on it
though the order will send to him Lindy
I was able to move the military and the
military had always been Mao's personal
guarantee of safety and here was someone
else who could move the military and by
right by right right given to him
actually by Mao himself and I think
that's what frightened my land as we try
to detail in the book that's what leads
Mao to saut chipping away at Lin beyond
its position and eventually to driving
him into a corner and we discussed
flight and the crash and all the rest of
it there's a very good book about this
whole episode two very good books
actually one by by Fred T Wilson
Warren's son called tragedy of India and
then there's the book by the daughter of
Rufus yen who was then commander of the
Air Force chinchou who's now a scholar
in this country and I'm blanking on the
title of the book which remember was Yeo
Jin titled in shows book anyway Xin chào
is her name and it's and it's about it's
about the Lin be our episode in which
her father was deeply involved but what
we try to do is to fit this using their
data as well into the whole pattern of
the Cultural Revolution the latter part
of the culture evolution after the Red
Guards had gone and everyone thanked God
for that
and after the Lin bi affair which
destroyed the image of what the culture
of Lucian was back for tens of thousands
of politically aware Chinese anyone who
had believed that the Cultural
Revolution was about something real and
important up to that time signed off
they they just turned off after that
because they began to feel was just a
power struggle and they'd seen this
before and
though it wasn't just a power struggle I
turned people off the Cultural
Revolution and the last years the
culture of Lucien Burr was stagnant
years still pretty awful years for China
as a whole and for many individuals at
the top of the of the Chinese party most
notably Joe and I who developed cancer
and of courses many of you will know was
not allowed to be operated on until the
chairman said oh yes well now we can
spare you for a little while maybe you
can do it and we don't know if the delay
in the operation would have had would
have had the decisive effect in Joe's
death but it certainly wasn't helpful in
his life well I could go on and on
there's a lot of pages there I could go
on and on about but I think at this
point maybe I should stop and see if you
have any questions about what I've said
or anything else yeah
there are so many young Chinese today
who are building a new country they're
the successful entrepreneurs they're
coming to this country to study and
they're in their 20s and 30s and they
really have no awareness or even memory
of the culture revolution and they're
looking forward they're now looking
backward and and I'd really like to know
what what you think is the enduring
relevance of the Cultural Revolution for
this new generation well I think the
most important relevance is and this is
sort of a a saying that goes around the
China field no Cultural Revolution no
reform had there been no Cultural
Revolution of China today would look
like East Germany in other words a
country very competently making the best
of a bad economic system because they're
Chinese that had done it better than
most but it wouldn't be good and what I
think we we draw these conclusions at
the end of the book what I think has
happened has been that at the end of the
Cultural Revolution well let me turn
step back at the beginning of the
Cultural Revolution a few people at
notice of the Japanese miracle at the
end of the Cultural Revolution
especially when Deng Xiaoping really
came back to par at the end of the 70s
begin 79 there are miracles all over
East Asia and China which had had the
best chance in 1949 when they took power
when Japan was spread-eagled a comic
bombed American occupation Korea was
about to be marched over again and again
Taiwan a beaten relic of the nationís
party an army and a couple of entrepot
sleepy rural entrepreneur and in Hong
Kong at that time China had the chance
to surge ahead and I think the calmness
must have thought that they would and
what
Dunc shopping realized thirty years
later and said benign is that they'd
screwed up they told themselves bad they
couldn't blame the in Paris they
couldn't blame foreign invasions they
could
only blame themselves and I think that
he had no plan in 79 he didn't know what
he was doing he saw what South Korea had
to achieve in economic development
he saw the sort of stability that
Singapore had achieved with the economic
development these seem to me good things
and he wanted to see what China could do
so you know the phrase crossing the
river by feeling from the stones that's
what he did and gradually really the 80s
was the period of the TV's time should
village enterprises collective
enterprises leading the surge of Chinese
exports into Walmart and boom booming
dales and so on and then the 90s we've
seen private enterprise begin to pick up
and still not too happy with it so I
would say to these young Chinese and
I'll say something about the ones I need
to I would say to these young Chinese
you really ought to know why you're
doing this because you no longer have
marxism-leninism as a faith it's up
there's a cardinal principle but no one
no one pays any attention you really
have to know why you did why this is
happening and you also ought to come to
terms with your history and they all was
attacking the Japanese for not coming to
terms the history I think is a sub
justification for that they praised the
Germans but they have emulated the
Germans I get Chinese students some of
them Chinese Americans now that parents
came over and they are now being brought
up in America some direct from China all
the Munda graduates in my culture
revolution course and three or four
Britain to me or come up to me said was
so grateful to you for this course
because granny and Grandpa or daddy and
mummy never told us anything about it
and I think they just have to come terms
this history not just because we need to
have them acknowledge this is what room
John would like to have that Chairman
Mao was something of a monster and that
his tomb should be taken out of tenement
square as picture should be taken down
and I would cheer if that happened not
just because that but because the really
terrible part of the Cultural Revolution
was that people did it to themselves I
mean what Mao did was to unleash people
this is not a controlled revolution that
would have been against
the spirit of the culture revolution he
unleashed them once he'd done away with
the party people in percent of the
leaders of the center he said you know
go forth and make revolution that's how
you gonna learn how to be revolution and
so they've got to understand how
important for instance the rule of law
is something which you are trying to
instill in courts in China I know if
they are going to prevent this kind of
thing from happening not necessarily on
the large scale that it happened in
China during the cut revolution but on
smaller scales because what they did to
each other was terrible yes sir
on your question and your comments to
the question the same general spirit as
a Jew I am acutely aware of the
Holocaust in my historical experience
though not personal family experience
there's very much a part of my being and
I'm absolutely stupefied at the
reluctance of the Chinese community be
it Chinese Chinese Chinese abroad
Chinese Americans I don't know of his
shame a culture of shame a culture of
silence or what but it's so contrary to
the memory of the victims and a sense of
even rudimentary justice if not judicial
justice to have an awareness of these
great crimes that have been inflicted on
this great people and an obliviousness
that is to me appalling well what do you
think is the source of this it's very
simple example and I want to introduce
you to one ear chin here who is in fact
has been detailing in the scholarly
manner the the crimes by students
against teachers in the Beijing and
elsewhere in the Cultural Revolution
she's not popular with some people as a
result the reason for this is very
simple and that is that Chairman Mao
dumps out being said this when they were
preparing the resolution when he was
talking to party historians who wrote
the resolution Chairman Mao is the basis
now of the legitimacy of the times comes
hee hee all the achievements he had
after 49 had been swept aside
collectivization nationalization
Cultural Revolution break before all
abandoned but he was the leader of the
party to victory and without him they
wouldn't be there and if you if you
dumped on him you don't have a lending
to fall back on as when Khrushchev
denounced Stalin if you dump on him
what's left
there's no Marxism Leninism no mal
what's the party doing there except that
it's there so Mao is the last shred of
legitimacy and a very important fig leaf
of legitimacy rather large fig leaf of
legitimacy for the party and that's why
they can't go into this I do have a
friend very actually he was my secretary
for for time but Phil thumb of him sent
away for 20 years for the Cultural
Revolution and he he when he came back
he became first deputy head of
organization and he wanted to throw out
all the people who were guilty of crimes
during the Cultural Revolution and he
was rapidly retired because that would
be calm in spite of China was 19 million
strong in 66 at the beginning occult
revolution it was 38 million strong at
the end of revolution he's going to kick
out 19 million people at another
Cultural Revolution so he was retired
and that never happened so that as you
possibly know people would come back
they'd finally be restored to to their
old reputation and they restore to their
job and sitting opposite them only on
the desk was the man who denounced them
replaced them whatever and they had to
live with that and I think that it's um
I think the grandparents and the parents
of young Chinese whether they're in
China or here who don't tell their kids
about this are really not teaching them
a lesson they ought to learn
yes ma'am to differ
I found I hadn't read the whole book but
I find the last revolution from what
you're talking is part of a chain of
attacks the Cultural Revolution and on
laws leadership that's sort of one-sided
and distorted and ate your picture of
the gpcr that you know you presented is
not just that it's a failure but that it
was a horror
it was anarchy it was you know something
that should never be be looked at again
and I think there's a whole nother
understanding of the Cultural Revolution
that I'm sure you're aware of and of
what happened in the actual history and
that is to uphold the accomplishments
that um that were that happened during
that period and also to look at and
criticized and evaluates the
shortcomings of that crucial period and
I just wanted to point out that speaker
is going to be coming to University of
Chicago sponsored by the center of East
Asian Studies and Raymond Lauda he's a
political economist and a Maoist and
he's going to give a pretty rousing
defense argument about the the period of
time of the Cultural Revolution and I
welcome everybody who can to come to
this I think this debate needs to be had
and we need to learn just like you were
the questioner was saying the Chinese
people need to know but all over the
world I think people really need to know
what it was that was the essence of that
revolution I think that you're I study
the book I think the history that you
have is important I don't issue that the
theme of Raymond's talk it's the Chang
holiday book and I think that's a
different kettle of fish
but now notwithstanding I think that
there's a enough value to looking at
what was accomplished in the Cultural
Revolution that we're not going to get
by reading this book and we should
really open our minds to and so that's a
Tuesday my husband
the gentleman is lucky not to experience
the Cultural Revolution personally as a
Chinese and I being should know that he
has is able to bring some Chinese along
who will say what a great thing it was
yes sir yeah well I think we you felt
hit the nail on the head there and you
were talking earlier on about memoir
some
sort of there's been lots of memoirs in
the last few decades that have been
coming out and lots of we can all meet
many Chinese who can talk about their
experiences in the Cultural Revolution
but two very important words that you
haven't mentioned so far at all
one is peasant one is worker and these
are the people who constitute the mass
majority of the Chinese people who can't
write their memoirs who because they
can't write in English maybe they can't
even write in Chinese still what you're
talking about you're saying that the
Chinese people are like all the same and
they all have this experience of the
sort of the urban elite even that who
are the people that are writing these
memoirs you're not talking at all about
what happened to the peasantry and the
workers like and I'm just sort of
wondering what you're bringing out
that's new in all of this because we're
hearing that Mao is like Hitler we've
heard from this gentleman here that the
Coache revolution is like the Holocaust
and things was what's new about all of
this well I think if you read the book
have you read the book no no maybe you
won't but if you read the book you will
find that we one of the things that we
have tried to do is to deal with the
question of what was happening to people
ordinary people you'll find quite a lot
about that what we hadn't realized until
the work we did and other people's work
was the extent to which what was thought
by scholars and by ourselves earlier on
to be in mainly an urban movement was in
fact something which penetrated to the
countryside and that some of the some of
the violence in the countryside was even
worse than some of the violence in the
cities so we do try and and indicate the
impact on the the peasants in fact in
some cases when car doors were being
attacked the peasants were rather
pleased because taxes weren't collected
so we try and insofar as the materials
allow we try and deal with ordinary
people because of course it was ordinary
people are affected as well as the elite
but what mal was about in the Cultural
Revolution was in fact transforming
daily
that's what it was about he wanted to
replace what he thought of as a
revolutionarily bankrupt set of
colleagues whom he'd worked with for 30
40 years by a new generation whom he was
going to give revolution experience by
setting them loose on the party and it
was utopian it was bad and it resulted
in him having eventually to call in the
army to and send off the Red Guards into
the countryside so it was about delete
as he said as he said in an article
which was published before the Cultural
Revolution the fate of the revolution
depends upon revolution successes and he
wasn't looking for revolution successes
among the peasant largely was looking
for them among the elite who were likely
to lead China masters into the history
of China and because the masses are
makers of history not you can't just say
that one man or a couple of men like
decide something and everything flows
from that and so that's where I think
that what you're sorting by it's really
one-sided in that respect and I mean I
lived in China and travelled in China
around the countryside for a year and
I've spoken to peasants who tell me like
I have like in the Cultural Revolution
we had better doctors coming for the
first time that we had health care why
we were able to like get hold of books
on study ourselves we like literate
literacy was like it became up to like
80% from 30% like before the revolutions
of people have talked to me about that
sort of thing some of its through
translation some fit through my basic
Chinese and I'm wondering why this never
comes out like in the West
well that that has come out actually
people have written about that I think
that and peasant who said to you that
literacy had gone up from 30% to 80% was
a very odd peasant who would know those
statistics even if they were true which
I doubt I think that
you've got to realize one thing I learnt
about it from a Chinese who I regard as
a friend he told one of my Chinese
students he said I say one thing to
party members I say another thing to
Chinese and I say a third thing to
foreigners so you've got to realize you
stick out like a sore thumb when you go
to Chinese countries then I applaud you
for doing it and talking to people
what's that
of course of course but you've got to
realise that and I think that the idea
that you're going to be told that the
Cultural Revolution was tremendous by
ordinary people in China
well you must met some very
extraordinary ordinary people they like
to say other revolution we have no firm
figures on that there's no way of
knowing what the number was one estimate
made by a scholar some years ago was
half a million dead many many more
injured
some of them crippled for life that
figure he is now put up perhaps to a
million million Harper diese estimates
would be honoring them we just don't
know what I was very surprised that some
years ago when talking to some Chinese
about cot revolution someone volunteered
the figure of ten million dead and I
just find this hard to believe
I then them tried it out on two other
sets of Chinese and they said yes if you
include the countryside probably 10
million eye-fi I still find it hard to
be this many as ten million I think we'd
have been spotted in the population
figures it would be that much but it was
a large number not as many as during
greatly famine which is variously
estimated somewhere between them
upwards of twenty eight thirty forty
million people something which is far
worse for the people at large the
cultural revolution the contribution was
terrible for the party and for officials
and bad for the people as well but not
nearly as bad as the great Dean Thurmond
but we don't have figures and with the
I'm sure there will be scholars in the
future Chinese and Western who will try
and add up the figures and people are
already tried doing with the publication
of local gazetteers and those are pretty
well complete down I think and the
figures will come out he'll another one
seven years a lot of foreign observers
of China perhaps had an idealistic image
of this revolution that was taking place
and they were forced to reassess over
time and you've been studying the
Cultural Revolution so long could you
talk a little bit about your personal
evolution as it stayed the same has a
change and if it's changed why is it
changed and also over the next 10 20
years how is our understanding going to
change even further well to answer the
last part of your question first I think
that it will be our understanding will
will increase as more local history as
done a lot of scholars are now borrowing
into these local archives and finding
out what happened between 66 and 76 to
the peasants and to the workers
particularly but also to the economy and
and society in general if you look at my
writings over the period I think I can
say I was never someone who felt that
this was a wonderful a wonderful affair
I was fascinated by how Mao was doing it
at the beginning how he set up one and
then another and they all fell that was
very intriguing and I don't understand
how colleagues
or others in the field could have been
deceived about the cultural revolution
since and say after it was all over we
didn't understand them so in violence
when there weren't thanked bodies
floating down the Pearl River to Hong
Kong and people refugees coming out who
telling what it was like as with the
great league famine you couldn't know
the full horror of it until afterwards
but there was enough to know that this
was not good for China oh right I just
like to perhaps contribute a somewhat
pessimistic note I don't think that the
kind of statistics you were hoping for
appear in the funk sure at all and it's
because at the grassroots level nobody
wants to think about it and of course as
you might know interviewed hundreds of
people in the countryside and I have yet
to find one who would like to in any way
relive that period then a general
strategy is to if at all possible simply
limit it's too embarrassing the way that
the social fabric was ripped apart in
the countryside it's just mind-blowing
for me to discover an even more
mind-blowing is that if you look in the
Encyclopedia Britannica under Cultural
Revolution in the first paragraph you
will see the statement that now this was
primarily an urban event and had very
little effect in the countries I had
enormous effect and never lasting one as
far as I could gather now I will stop
that wasn't a question it was just a no
it was very interesting comment I think
I hope you're wrong
because just for the sake of the
historical record I think Andrew Walder
is discovering some things in the local
gazetteers which give him some basis for
a larger number than before but
obviously you're actually right people
just don't want to and partly because
they don't think it will be good for
them if they do numbers follows the
general pattern of what we will call
genocide studies the numbers will get
bigger in the study of American Indian
demographic losses after the Columbian
encounter the numbers have going up from
estimates from the 1920s continuously to
today from 2 million to something like
120 million with them stronger
evidentiary basis than the two million
guesses guesswork of 80 years ago the
number of victims of the Nazis non-jews
of genocide or cold-blooded slaughter
have grown substantially the number of
victims of various Soviet regimes has
grown if China follows a pattern I think
the evidence is naturally inclined to
produce larger figures I don't know if
that what that trend will apply to China
or not but it will only be found out if
Chinese do the finally out the highest
estimate I've seen of of great leap
forward deaths which was 42 million was
done by a senior official who was
entrusted by then Prime Minister Zhao
Ziyang
with going round the country and looking
at three sets of records to try and
determine each province what was the
total and he came to that conclusion
looking at the good public security
records the local records and as a third
set of records I'd forgotten so yes we
may see the figures may well go up I
don't know but I think I suspect it will
have to be in a different atmosphere
political atmosphere and with Chinese
historians doing the work
yes sir I'm sorry if I missed this
because I came in late but have you said
anything about what happened to Tibet
no this abnormal science to Tibet Tibet
yes well I hadn't it though Tibet many
religious establishments were trashed
monks were were given the same treatment
as people on in in China proper and as
you may know who you are born then
general secretary in the early 80s
apologized in Tibet for all that had
been done and actually not just the
Cultural Revolution but even before so
quite horrific things were done there
but by the standards of the mainland it
was the China problems not anything
extraordinary in fact you know if
anything they got off lightly because
it's difficult for the Red Guards to get
there
apparently the same vein as as a
showman's question I was wondering
what's been the legacy of the occult
revolution for Chinese Muslims
especially on in Shenzhen well I've just
been in Shin Jung and I don't think that
it's the Cultural Revolution
particularly I mean it had its problems
the same as Tibet
religion was attacked generally
Christianity Buddhism Islam